E
STREAM.
>> Ben: THANK YOU.
ALSO HERE TONIGHT, FORMER HAWAII
CONGRESSWOMAN AND FORMER
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE TULSI
GABBARD.
SO, TULSI, TELL ME, DO YOU THINK
THAT PARENTS NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT HEADING TO
GITMO?
>> EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW, BEN.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT BIGGER
THAN DEMOCRATS VS. REPUBLICANS.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING HERE IS ABOUT
THE POWERFUL ELITE IN THIS
COUNTRY USING THEIR POWER TO TRY
TO SILENCE AND CONTROL US.
WHAT IS SO DANGEROUS ABOUT THIS
SITUATION IS WE HAVE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ESSENTIALLY
WEAPONIZING OUR FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
INTIMIDATE AND SILENCE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO TRY TO
SILENCE US INTO COMPLIANCE,
ESSENTIALLY.
AND THE REALITY IS THAT, AS YOU
KNOW VERY WELL, WHETHER WE
DISAGREE OR AGREE WITH EACH
OTHER, WHETHER OUR SPEECH IS
QUIET OR OBNOXIOUS.
OUR SPEECH IS PROTECTED BY THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I, AS A
SOLDIER, AND AS A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS TOOK AN OATH TO SUPPORT
AND DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION AND
I MAY HATE THE SPEECH THAT YOU
SAY.
I MAY COMPLETELY DISAGREE WITH
IT, BUT I WILL LAY DOWN MY LIFE
TO PROTECT YOUR RIGHT TO SAY IT.
>> Ben: ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
CONCERNS ME SO MUCH ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR MOMENT, TULSI, IS
THAT IT'S NOT NECESSARILY ABOUT
THE PEOPLE WHO YOU HEAR ABOUT
GETTING INTO FIGHTS OVER THIS.
WHO ACTUALLY HAVE TO GO TO COURT
AND DEFEND THEMSELVES.
IT'S ABOUT ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
STAY QUIET BECAUSE OF THE FORCES
OF THE ELITE, BECAUSE OF BIG
TECH, BECAUSE OF BIG GOVERNMENT,
BEING POTENTIALLY USED AGAINST
THEM.
THEY ESSENTIALLY ARE SCHEDULED
INTO SILENCE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO BE AT THE END OF THAT
SPEAR.
>> AND THAT'S WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT FOR US TO STAND UP TO
SPEAK OUT, TO FIGHT BACK, TO
TAKE A STAND FOR OUR FREEDOM.
THE KIND OF ACTION THAT WE'RE
SEEING FROM ATTORNEY GENERAL
GARLAND, IT MAKES OUR COUNTRY
LOOK MORE AND MORE LIKE WE ARE
MOVING TO A POLICE STATE RATHER
THAN BEING THE LAND OF THE FREE
AND SO NOW IS NOT THE TIME TO
ALLOW THEM TO INTIMIDATE US INTO
SILENCE.
NOW IS THE TIME THAT WE, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE MUST TAKE THIS
STAND FOR EACH OTHER, FOR OUR
CIVIL LIBERTIES, FOR OUR
FREEDOMS, BECAUSE,
UNFORTUNATELY, THOSE WHO ARE IN
POWER, THOSE WHO ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE LEADING OUR COUNTRY, RATHER
THAN UPHOLDING OUR CIVIL
LIBERTIES AND FREEDOMS, THESE
KINDS OF ACTIONS ARE VIOLATING
AND INFRINGING UPON THEM.
>> Ben: I KNOW THAT YOU IN
CONGRESS WERE ONE OF THE MAJOR
VOICES PUSHING BACK AGAINST THE
ASSUMPTION THAT WE SHOULD JUST
TAKE FOR GRANTED INTELLIGENCE,
SECURITY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY JUST
PLACES THAT WE SHOULD TRUST
AUTOMATICALLY.
YOU WANT TO SEE THEM HAVE MORE
OVERSIGHT AND MORE TRANSPARENCY
BECAUSE YOU FELT THAT WE NEEDED
TO BE MORE SKEPTICAL.
THAT'S NOT BEEN SOMETHING THAT I
THINK TRADITIONALLY A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS LISTEN TO.
BUT A LOT MORE OF THEM ARE
LISTENING TO IT NOW.
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE STEPS THAT
WE CAN TAKE TO HAVE MORE
CONFIDENCE THAT WE WON'T SEE A
SITUATION WHERE THINGS LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ARE BEING
TURNED AGAINST OUR OWN LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS?
>> WELL, WHEN YOU HEAR SO EASILY
IN THIS SPECIFIC EXAMPLE THE
COUNTER-TERRORISM DIVISION OF
OUR GOVERNMENT, THE NATIONAL
SECURITY BRANCH BEING INVOKED TO
TARGET EVERYDAY AMERICANS, TO
TARGET THESE PARENTS WHO,
BECAUSE THEY CARE SO MUCH FOR
THEIR CHILDREN, ARE GOING AND
SPEAKING OUT AT THESE BOARD OF
EDUCATION MEETINGS, WHEN YOU SEE
THIS HAPPENING, IT SHOULD BE A
RED FLAG BEING WAIVED TO EVERY
SINGLE PERSON ABOUT THE DANGER
OF THESE PROVISIONS THAT WERE
PASSED IN THE PATRIOT ACT AFTER
9/11 TO SPECIFICALLY GO AFTER
AL-QAEDA THE JIHADIST TERRORISTS
WHO ATTACKED US ON THAT DAY NOW
BEING REDIRECTED TOWARDS OUR
NEIGHBORS, OUR FRIENDS, THOSE IN
OUR COMMUNITY, OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS.
SO WE CAN ONLY PUT A STOP TO
THIS LAWMAKERS ACCOUNTABLE SO
THAT THESE POLICY CHANGES ARE
MADE SO THAT THESE PROVISIONS IN
THE PATRIOT ACT ARE REVOKED.
THIS IS WHAT I WAS WORKING ON IN
CONGRESS AND WE ARE SEEING NOW
SO IMP